in March of 2016 Apple released the
iPhone se which is basically meant to
compete with lower end smartphones
giving people access to an iPhone for a
much cheaper $400 Apple got to that low
price by using previous gen hardware and
a lot of people loved it now there are
tons of rumors of a brand new iPhone se
- or possibly named iPhone 9 coming next
month in March just like the original se
did four years ago however the world has
changed drastically in the last four
years including some major new markets
like India which are waiting for the
perfect smartphone and I believe that
smartphone is the iPhone 9 so before I
explain why this iPhone is incredibly
important to the future of Apple let me
go through a list of all the rumors I
could find on the details of this new
budget iPhone as I've mentioned before
it'll most likely be released next month
at Apple's annual March event but there
are some worries about the coronavirus
delaying its release and I'll talk about
that in just a minute just like the
original SC borrowed hardware from a
previous iPhone the iPhone 9 should also
be reusing an old design and hardware
like having the same design as the
iPhone 8 with a 4.7 inch display large
bezels on the top and bottom in a touch
ID sensor however there is a small
chance that will actually get face ID on
this iPhone but most rumors say
otherwise the iPhone 9 could be a bit
thicker than the eight to allow for a
bigger battery as well as packing the
same main camera as the iPhone 11 but
possibly excluding the ultra wide lens
this is great news because rumours point
to the iPhone 9 being priced at around
$400 so you're getting an incredibly
good camera at a great price
I personally think that the camera
layout will change a bit like maybe
having a larger camera bump to ensure
that you can't use old iPhone 8 cases on
this new iPhone 9 it should use the same
aluminum frame a glass back with
wireless charging possibly a censored
Apple logo in the same a 13 chip with 3
gigabytes of RAM from the iPhone 11
which is very powerful and as for the
storage we're expecting it to
at 64 gigabytes so in reality you're
really getting a lot for the $400 price
tag and I'll explain why a price tag
this low still makes financial sense at
the end of this video
now askin is a-- why this iphone 9 is
such a huge deal for Apple believe it or
not there are a ton of people who are
still using the iPhone 6 6s or even the
original se and there's a couple of
reasons why they've abstained from
upgrading for so long
first off newer iPhones are quite a bit
more expensive than before so people who
don't care much about new technology
don't see the value in upgrading some
users really don't like the idea of face
ID so they're not able to let go of the
home button on the other hand others
simply don't like the large size of all
the latest iPhones the new iPhone 9
would virtually fix all of those issues
being affordable and packing a
super-fast chip this translates to a lot
of people with older iPhones finally
upgrading especially if Apple offers a
really good trade-in program this
ultimately means more sales of iPhones
and accessories like cases but that's
not even the biggest deal for Apple
while a lot of people in the States can
afford iPhones there are a lot of
countries that don't have it so easy
namely India and China and in those
countries budget smartphones rule the
market for a couple of different reasons
first off there aren't as many high
paying jobs there so it's more difficult
for the vast majority of people to buy
an expensive iPhone and in the case of
India there are tariffs on imported
iPhones so they can potentially be more
expensive than they are here in the
States here's a fact that you may find a
bit hard to believe last year Apple's
iPhone 10 are from 2018 was the best
selling smartphone in the world yes you
heard that right last year's iPhone 10
are selling better than any other
smartphone this quote from India
times.com explains why Apple also
adjusted the price of the iPhone 10 are
in China and several other markets like
India which helped keep demand strong
during the quarter and check out this
article saying that India has a massive
market of 480 million smartphones with
Apple's current share of that market
sitting at just over 1%
because of the high price of Apple's
premium smartphones however it was among
the fastest-growing smartphone brands in
India in the quarter to December 2019
and that's all thanks to the success of
the iPhone 10 are and now the iPhone 9
is about to take that spot at a much
lower $400 price tag making it more
attainable to markets where the budget
smartphone is king now on the topic of
the coronavirus quite a few factories
that assemble iPhones have been closed
down but in recent news more factories
are beginning to resume production in
China so even with these delays Apple is
still rumored to launch the iPhone 9 at
their March event next month on the
topic of tariffs causing iPhones to be
more expensive in India Apple has
actually been working on an answer to
this problem for years there are already
multiple iPhone manufacturing facilities
in India including wished Iran which has
been assembling lower end iPhone models
like the SE for years with one goal in
mind
avoiding import tariffs and making these
iPhones cheaper for the Indian market
last month it was reported that which
Tron's third plants in India is ramping
up iPhone production so that adds too
many rumors of the upcoming iPhone se 2
or iPhone 9 being assembled in India
alongside China and due to the corona
virus it was reported that Foxconn has
moved some of its iPhone production to
India as well this ultimately means that
the Indian market is getting the iPhone
9 without having to pay the import taxes
for the phone itself the main problem
Apple's gonna have is keeping up with
the demand since their Indian factories
aren't as capable as the ones in China
especially since the Chinese market is
going to be all over the iPhone 9 as
well so the point of all this info is
this if the one year old iPhone 10 R was
able to grab the spot for the
best-selling smartphone in the world
imagine how well the brand new iPhone 9
for $200 less is gonna perform and with
more and more iPhones in the hands of
people in markets like China and India
that means more organic advertising in
terms of word-of-mouth or increase in
popularity within their culture and
that's just the tip of the iceberg in
Apple's master plan since the $400 price
tag of the
phone 9 doesn't leave much room for
profit margin Apple is instead relying
on getting more people in lower markets
into the Apple ecosystem this means more
people having access to the iOS App
Store and buying apps and games more
people paying for Apple software like
iCloud in Apple music subscriptions more
people buying an Apple wash because they
now have an iPhone more people buying
iPads buying Mac books buying air pods
and more that is apple's master plan in
the long-term goal of giving more of the
global market access to anything and
everything Apple is worth not making
very great profit margins on the $400
iPhone 9 we're also expecting them to
release the 2020 iPad pro next month in
March so if you're interested in leaks
and rumors on that make sure to check
out that video right over there and if
you're not already subscribed click that
circle above to do so now because we're
going to be reviewing the iPhone 9 as
soon as we get our hands on it thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]